quand j'étais petit parce que moi aussi
j'étais petit quand j'étais petit je
regardais la télévision à l'époque sang
noir et blanc
il y avait trois émissions que j'ai
adoré par dessus tout et qui m'ont
beaucoup influencé finalement il y avait
dit mme dam dom daisy de galard il y
avait les raisins verts de jean
christophe averty et l'émission de
benjamin castaldi et l'émission de
benjamin castaldi qui s'appelle c'est
vrai que ça fait déjà célébrités non il
y avait une autre émission qui
s'appelait un égal 3 c'était jacques
martin et jean yanne
ah
oui là respect
vous savez il faut rendre hommage à un
martin parce que c'est une émission que
lui avait eu c'était c'est à lui qu'on
l'avait demanda bon et c'est lui qui m'a
fait venir eh ben il a eu raison parce
que c'est vachement riant vers un bout
tout à l'heure vous avez vu le nombre de
fiches que j'ai sur bull c'est
incroyable et jamais autant de fiches
sur canal m sur quoi un livre à vous
n'êtes pas sorti bien alors on va
commencer tout de suite par la promo
comme ça sera fait 1 alors attention
c'est comment on fait hacker petites
mains
comme les sourds-muets gamme de soin qui
commençait pas avec les sourds muets csu
plein 10 miles ont elles changé après
inventé ce que vous voulez bien sûr
surtout vous attention 1-2-3
tout faire ben si
bien bien alors donc jean yanne vous
publiez un bouquin qui s'appelle le
dictionnaire des mots qui a que moi qui
les connaît dial titre vachement bien
c'est chez plon c'est des mots que vous
avez inventé vous hein alors par exemple
page 25 non mais j'ai noté comme ça
quelques uns qui vont bien ferrer 25 à
baluch riz par exemple alors une baluch
free c'est une phrase stupide
exemple la démocratie s'arrête où
commence la raison d'état cette qui sait
de main square il ya phrase houle s'est
excusé une phrase ou laurent non oui
j'ai lu attentivement le livre de jean
qu'il est un maître que je vénère comme
henri salvador c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
que c'est la deuxième fois que je vois
respectueux pour quelques uns des dieux
vivants pour moi
donc continuez comme ça quand ça
commence comme ça on voit déjà les
chandeliers les mécary noir sapin ça
ressemble à des crocs un peu c'est
vraiment tout le temps si à la fin il
n'y a pas moins qu'ils répondent mais
mesure où je serais vous je
m'inquiéterais jorian je t'admire et
même quand tu étais jeune donc voilà
rien à voir avec la mort alors une fois
zulic certes
une phrase houle c'est un vampire se
nourrissant uniquement du sont deux
jeunes filles vierges et dont l'espèce a
complètement disparu pour cette raison
évidemment c'est une phrase houle alors
après j'en ai encore ah oui j'en ai un
qui est drôle c'est inclus mieux plutôt
mou et pas très net ça allait bien ce
que ça veut dire le travail effectué par
madame cresson pendant son séjour à la
commission de bruxelles est
incontestablement glu mieux passé que
des trucs comme ça c'est des mots donc
cédé manque de l'inventer oui mais chez
les mots que j'ai inventé après la
définition ah oui c'est ça sert vous
avez commencé je vais pas commencer à
prendre des définit un ponte des mots
puis à chercher ce que ça voulait dire
prêt chez cd définition puis après j'ai
cherché quel est le mot qui
correspondait le plus à ça ouais alors
par exemple il ya it l'opel alors que
l'open c'est une réunion de
personnalités désignées par l'état
pourrait assumer dans l'audiovisuel des
fonctions bien au dessus de leurs
compétences ce qui gêne considérablement
le travail des gens qualifiés alors vise
personne évidemment face est assez et on
voit tout de suite de qui il s'agit i gr
big aussi alors il rabique bon à rien
graphique de tout le service public la
télévision française peut se vanter de
posséder le plus grand nombre 10 gr bic
et s'ils voulaient ya un fond de vérité
au tout les toutes les 10 ou 15
définition il y en a une de bonne
c'est des mots qui risque d'être d'être
employé ça j'espère qu'ils vont être
employés ça n'est jamais arrivé de faire
quoi que ce soit qui ne soit repris un
jour ou l'autre par un homme politique
bah oui mais sait-on pidoux avait dit
tout le monde il est beau tout le monde
il est gentil
et il y avait comme ça il ya des tas de
trucs qui sont entrés dans le temps là
dans la langue il est interdit
d'interdire quand même jorian a inventé
en 68 tout le monde croit que c'est des
étudiants du quartier latin qui l'ont
inventé c'est vous qui l'avez inventé un
matin sur rtl oui il est interdit
d'interdire qui est devenu en tout le
monde croit que ça a été fait par des
étudiants gauchistes si je vois qu'il ya
des gens comme vous qui rétablisse la
vérité qui a je suis là pour ça
ça m'a coûté assez cher les crs ss et de
toi crs et cette adresse ses sincères et
ccc pas de maman j'ai inventé le peuple
aura ta peau sur les pavés les frites
non
dieu est grand allah et aux enzymes
alors si vous dites que c'est un
dictionnaire qui contrairement aux
autres puissent être ouverts n'importe
quelle page pour y trouver ce qu'on
cherche pas oui parce qu'il a été écrit
comme ça ouais à partir du moment où il
a été écrit sans sans plan et au fur et
à mesure j'ai été dans des endroits où
je pouvais pas écrire des choses très
très compliqué j'avais seulement des
petites fiches et j'écrivais des petites
notes pour moi des fois j'ai éclaté de
rire j'étais content j'en trouvais une
bonne alors j'étais content et je pense
que les gens doivent se lire comme ça et
les lignes l'idéal c'est de le mettre
dans les toilettes à mon avis c'est ce
que tout le monde va faire alors c'est
un vide qui a été écrit dans l'est dans
les avions effectivement
vous voyagez beaucoup en fait non quand
vous dites à un moment page 79 les
toilettes des avions d'air france sont
abyss conique c'est à dire quoi visco ni
salle salle voilà d'une façon générale
tout ce qui est sûr air france est raté
mais
alors il ya les toilettes qui sont mal
nettoyé les hôtesses de l'air qui sont
des grands mères de lente et les et les
plateaux repas 10 on a bouffé alors
éventuellement renoncer au fait de te
faire surclasser
vous avez le goût des voyages vous c'est
marrant c'est un truc c'est vraiment
votre passion non mais oui mais vous
dites ya une sensation extraordinaire
c'est dans un avion finalement pire
moment il ya le pilote qui lie la votre
droite c'est le mont kenya votre gauche
c'est l'île maurice est vrai que c'est
plaisant jeudi je regarde toujours mal
et je suis pas du tout blasé je regarde
toujours par lapin là par le hublot
c'est tout à fait formels de casseurs
il y en a une ou deux
qu'ils se défendent pas sans les
attaquer venir
c'est du reste à y avait dans le temps
avec les hôtesses d'air france une
espèce de d'habitude de la carte
assiette de joutes sur les lignes
brésilienne notamment
saisi les fonds selon ce que se demande
si c'est pas le site web qui est déguisé
genre à parler un petit peu de vous
parce que moi je connais votre vie par
caps comme je disais tout à l'heure
dès l'âge de cheval de 13 14 ans je
regardais ben ouais mais là il ya des
gens qui vous connaissent pas donc
[Applaudissements]
déjà première révélation des soirées et
jean yanne ne s'appelle pas jean yanne
jorian s'appelle
jean gougy jeudi a fait changer en même
temps et même pendant mon enfance il ya
eu beaucoup de
d'utilisation un peu annexes et décalé
de montbray et pourquoi yann c'est mon
prénom yann parce que je suis d'origine
bretonne gouhier ça veut dire petit
marrant que c'est joli tout ça alors
vous dites que vous êtes né donc j'étais
en 33 on peut le dire et vous dites
alors quand on est né en 33 ans et tous
farsi1
il y avait d'abord tous les ans en
examen parce que le certif c'était en
deux parties le diplôme d'études
primaires en deux parties le brevet
élémentaire le bepc fameux bepc on te
parle si l'on appelait les classes
nouvelles c'est dire que jusqu'à la
guerre de vingt ans quand on est né en
tournoi on a sept ans à l'arrière et on
commence à aller vraiment de au collège
à 10 ans 11 ans et là c'était les
classes nouvelles après la guerre donc
on essayait tout en deux parties voilà
donc je me suis toujours dit qu'on
ferait en deux parties et le service
militaire faut dire qu'à l'époque
c'était 28 mois quand même à 32,30 deux
res c'est terrible ça il ya la prison là
dedans
un placard il ya qua non il ya eu un
petit peu de prison mais pas longtemps
parce que comme c'était la guerre
d'algérie on m'avait mis en prison à la
caserne duplex et la prison était un peu
dans sous sol ah oui et moi je
je me trompe je me pensais au soupirail
je disais je suis arabe et atom torture
a coupé la machine alors les gens
avaient protesté désavoue torture et les
arabes maintenant mes lives entre
excuses et bientôt beaucoup bien alors
votre père était ébéniste et ensuite
lithographe abord little c'est un point
de vue mais c'est bien heureusement vous
êtes là comme ça se fait corriger mes
flèches mais il faisait des lithos de
benjamin rabier ça c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai mais justement où bonne question
mais un jeune arabe il c'est le type qui
a dessiné la vache qui rit quand même
c'est pas avec c'est vrai et oui votre
mère était couturière oui chez madeleine
vionnet et chez lanvin oui juste vous
allez au lycée chaptal diaconesses
turgot lycée chaptal c'est bien voir si
koné savic l'école de journalisme vous
avez été virés vous êtes parti non je
suis j'ai pas été jusqu'à la fin j'ai
pas été viré je suis pas parti c'est à
dire que les deux premières années
c'était
l'école normale à partir de la troisième
année c'était les techniques de la
presse donc là sa demande était un peu
l'imprimerie l'école estienne tout ça il
ya bien deux journalistes mais pas
humble et mark wallace a mal fait et
alors là après la guerre vous rencontrez
quelqu'un qui s'appelle bob du parc à
saint germain il s'appelle bob du pack
de mars ni du gamay de toy non tv
d'encre jetez pas cette place sur la
fiche pour tous marqués non ce qui est
génial c'est que là vous faites du que
vous commencez à faire du cabaret et
vous faites un cabaret rue de rivoli une
histoire insensée qui s'appelle
l'académie des vins blancs a expliqué
nous parce que là il y avait des gens
qui venaient l'écart qui venait comment
ça se passe et non c'était il y avait un
cabaret qui était rue de rivoli qui doit
s'appeler le slow club maintenant qui
est au 2eme vois bien une affiche en mer
deuxième étages en sous sol et
le pâton ils appâtent one avait trouvé
un truc c'est qu'il y avait des cars qui
faisait la tournée des grands ducs à
paris dans l'ouest au lido à pigalle et
il fallait une cave saint germain des
prés mais c'était très dur de se garer à
saint-germain-des-prés c'était beaucoup
plus facile de se garer à rue de rivoli
et comme les touristes n'y voyait que du
feu les cars arrivaient à saint germain
des prés et nous on avait fait un
spectacle qui était qu'ils n'avaient pas
de début qu'ils n'avaient pas de faim
savait pas d'importance puisque quand le
car arrivé au ont sonné les types
descendait le spectacle était commencée
et au bout de quelques temps le guide
leur disais bon bah c'est terminé pour
partir et il partait avant que ce soit
fini et alors il fallait vraiment
accrédités saint-germain dépassé à que
vous en faites vous jouiez le temps oui
bon ok c'était la touriste était là prêt
direct disons non au lido et une semaine
et alors on avait on avait un moment
mais il faut quand même que ce soit plus
saint germain des prés alors on a trouvé
un mec qui ressemblait à sartre et on
l'a mis dans un coin avec un bloc il
l'écrivait les images ça c'est jean paul
sartre qui entend décrocher
l'or à fait
josiane entre dans le chenil le show
business unit choi
les niches et des cheminées vous êtes
engagés aux trois bonnets par jacques
canetti après un service militaire et là
faut reconnaître que vous avez une bonne
gage vous étiez chargé du costume soul
ou lyon c'est vrai ça
c'est pas vrai c'est un flux c'est pas
moi qui fais les fiches c'est moi qui ai
fait mes fils que c'est vrai c'est moi
qui fais mes filles simplement vous avez
dû le déclarer vous avez vu les gars et
un jour je vous étiez s'est torché que
j'avais pu le dire le service militaire
je faisais le costume sous louer un an
j'étais jeune j'ai fait mon service
militaire dans pas la première partie
militaire au service historique de
l'armée oui mais quand on est au service
historique de l'armée on n'écrit pas
forcément l'histoire des jupons et
l'histoire du vêtement souvient qu'il
n'était pas fou de l'armée non j'étais
au service torride armée ou en classe
est toutes les choses qui concerne l
armée et toutes les choses militaire un
gars comme ça vous permettait de
continuer à vous occuper de vos
activités sociales des loisirs bon alors
là c'est l'époque des cabarets alors se
dit plus rien à personne aujourd'hui les
cabarets l'amiral club 55 des trucs plus
personne ne sait ce que c'est alors à
l'époque va vous faites vous rencontrer
jacques martin fait cette émission
mythique qui s'appelle un égal froid on
va voir d'ailleurs un sketch que
j'oserais dire avant tu sais que j'ai
reçu un email d'un dénommé laurent
picone qui est un français qui habitent
en hollande et qui me dit ma femme et
moi on a décidé de faire un enfant et de
l'appeler serge et quand l'enfant sera
né on lui offrira un chien et on
l'appellera manier tout
tu verras ce que tu voudras fredo mais
dans cette année gros de beethoven on
sent encore vachement n'influence de
mozart faut dire que c'est la période
charnière de l'évolution beethovénienne
je suis d'accord avec toi mais c'est
plus sensible dans l'allée grande dans
l'adagio en filigrane par le fait c'est
sa deuxième manière à beethoven
c'est du bac pareil c'est du passé
produire shoah
j'ai petit jour
c'est françois janvier
ouais ça vraiment pas à
me tu reconnais pas la taille c'est
adrian flambard son billet il joue plus
délié dans les aigus samedi dernier
genou wendel et mauvaise foi vous des
invalides pour entendre du trajet bien
du froid et des lieux des biens du xv
quoi moi je lui
trouve qu'il a une bonne persistance
rythmé doigts et u15 serment il joue
bien mais il sait pas se servir de la
deuxième viole de gambe
ça des fois il a enregistré son tout su
mais quand il a un bon instrument comme
en guise dé van je vais lire à un peu
qui
des extraits
père guy gilbert je souhaitais que celle
du fret je m'en irai un peu tôt
ouais je suis le roseau dressé dans le
désert de la chrétienté je suis là
triste fleurs flétri sous le par des
païens je suis la collante qui chante
dans la chapelle du créateur je suis le
cri d'amour de l'occident
ça nous
va pas ils ont fait divers mais j'ai
choisi le passage le plus mince ou que
ta être parce que je vois plus clair tu
m'aimes
janvier
mais aussi pour iag il plane ya aussi
permis de conduire qui est très connu
qui est en latin que tout le monde
connaît le permis de conduire est alors
en 64 il ya eu un sketch relancer une
histoire terrible c'est un sketch les
napoléon qui faisait une course cycliste
avec ses généraux un et c'est lui qui
vous a fait virer ceux là ou non non non
celui qui nous a fait virer
non celui qui nous a fait virer c'est
une
une séance qui se passait dans une
église est où
moi j'étais en train de mettre des
fleurs sur l'autel et puis martin entré
en moto
rozier c'était moi et qui décorait et
martin de déshabiller et ils me le
faisaient du gringue à ebay c'est ma
salopette
là ça a été dur et puis un autre truc
aussi où je faisais schmelzer vous jouez
viens poupoule alors là ça n'est plus
tellement aux gens du alors voilà donc
c'est donc moi ça a été pour moi
fondateur je pense pour beaucoup de gens
aussi et en 65 rencontres et claude
chabrol et vous faites des films très
important au fait le boucher la ligne de
démarcation que la bête meure enfin qui
sont des films très important godard
vous faites week end il a un film aussi
très important et puis après ça s'est un
petit peu gâté mais vous dites tout le
monde croit que j'ai joué des navets
puis après les bons films en fait j'ai
commencé par les bons films beau j'ai
commencé sur des bons si j'ai fait les
navets après ouais c'est ça mais j'ai
fait les navets
avec une certaine volupté
c'est pas parce que m a pas engagés dans
des banques est la preuve je trouvais ça
bien de faire des films ou séries qui
après les navettes a refait des bons
films je viens sans arrêt
vous savez il ya eu à cette époque là
les
les comiques faisait très peu de temps
dans les films d'harry cole faisait une
demi-journée dans un fan et ça suffisait
pas ce que les gens allaient devoir il
entendait alors qu'est ce que c'est que
raconte le caillou les gens étaient
ravis alors tous les tous les gens qui
faisaient des films voulait avoir au
moins une demi-journée ou une journée
d'alcool et moi j'étais avec francis
blanche et nous on nous mettait tout le
temps dans le fond il y avait des scènes
qui se passait dans les films n'importe
n'importe où et nous on parlait on
faisait les métèques on était au bar et
on parlait et alors le metteur en scène
visée alesi parlé entre vous allez on
parlait alors bon quand on sait plus
quoi dire on avait un code et on disait
je suis catholique comme vous ça c'était
le
franchiseur je suis fatigué alger manger
traque mondiale était très difficile et
puis je suis rentré tard la maison et
puis moi je vais vous dire je suis
catholique comme vous
alors je savais qu'ils diraient plus
rien il fallait que j'enchaîne alors jeu
mais qu'est ce que vaut la peau de
plaisanterie facile
moi aussi je jusqu'à ce que jean de
sutton spur ya eu
le temps de chercher pendant
six à là c'est un truc qu'on trouvera
pas parce qu'évidemment ça a été foutu à
poubelles mais c'est la même chose qu'il
ya six à huit prises et a eu prise
différents et des civils jamais une
chose est ce que vous croyez vous êtes
un grand acteur s couperet que vous êtes
un grand acteur parce que vous prenez ça
par dessus la jambe
non non pas du touch down en jeu je
serai pas dire surtout à la télévision
française devant des milliards de gens
dans le monde qui parle français et pas
si bien dire
que je suis un grand acteur jeudi sinon
c'est un grand acteur six jours merci
beaucoup je mange dit simplement je suis
un acteur plausible si dire je n'ai
jamais fait une chose qui me paraissent
pas plausible un don si on me demande de
faire un vétérinaire je connais des
vétérinaires qu'on ma tête mon allure
montre ouvertement je préfère un
vétérinaire si on me demande de faire un
camion jusqu'au les camionneurs comme
mon allure mon comportement je peux
conduire un camion si on me demande de
faire un pianiste romantique avec george
sand là je fais pas c'est tout je peux
pas faire l'aiglon alors quand vous avez
le prix à cannes le prix
d'interprétation pour pia là pour nous
ne désirons pas ensemble un film
remarquable vous alors tout le monde
vous admire tout le monde chante vos
louanges et vous vous dites montre il
suffisait que je baisse les yeux pour
voir l'air triste jeu baisser les yeux
pour regarder mon texte ont fait l'essai
pense-bête partout dans la voiture et
tout le monde crie au génie oui mais je
peux plus le faire parce que je vois
plus clair alors avant je pouvais
baisser les lieux lui remet en texte en
photo et on disait il est triste
maintenant si je dis tu sais j'ai de la
peine et
comme vous il ya un mec était comme vous
c'était le chancelier adenauer parce que
lui c'est pareil vous dites on a
toujours cru qu'ils étaient vachement
sérieux adenauer avait eu une brisure
urinaire cité le chancelier allemand
après la guerre c'est le premier
chancelier allemand alors il a une
blessure de guerre qui lui a coupé les
zygomatiques et les zygomatiques ils
sont de chaque côté du sperme genre je
sais pas comment il a pu prendre un
éclat d'obus ou double qui lui a coupé
les deux mais ils n'auraient pas ils
pouvaient pas faire autrement il ya un
mec qui fait ça mieux que moi dans le
dallas dans la lecture des des textes
c'est brando ouais bon dos ils touchent
pas une bille il va le connais jamais
son texte quand il l'a fait après lips
now il devait sortir d'une grotte et on
pouvait la scène était filmée d'un
bateau qui était sur la rivière donc on
pouvait paraître un prompteur on pouvait
pas mettre quelque chose pour qu'ils
lisent alors on a dû mettre son texte de
l'autre côté de la rivière il a fallu
mettre un texte de 1 mètre de haut
j'ai écrit son texte à la bombe
et vous vous dites plus je souris plus
j'ai l'air triste je défends vous dis
souris sourit c'est vrai on a tout le
temps envie de vous dire pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas l'air content sourit et
souriez pour voir la
yamaha
quand vous dites a finalement que les
tracteurs bah oui c'est comme un
cordonnier qui a pris à réparer des
chaussures depuis l'âge de 19 ans et j'y
connais bien son métier on lui demande
pas d'être passionné quoi on a le
sentiment vous faites ça comme ça vous
faites très très bien mais avec une
espèce de distance je crois que c'est le
principe même du
du bon travail c'est à dire que on n'a
jamais on y est il n'ya pas d'oscar de
la plomberie non on comprenait il n'y a
pas deux il n'ya pas de gens qui se
félicite corporatives mans à longueur de
journée comme nous bon je sais que ça
vous a beaucoup touché d'avoir le 7 d'or
puisque j'ai vu des larmes couler sur
vos jours
mais bon vous rendez compte il y avait
les sept d'heures de la pâtisserie s'est
dressé comme les camionneurs c'est comme
les routiers viendrai pleurer et alors
là vont continuer la vie de jean yanne
qui est passionnante
alors au delà de cette mélodie qu'on
connaît tous il faut savoir que tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde était
gentil était le premier film anti pub
anti société de consommation anti radios
commerciales les mecs ils bouffaient des
le big band des années avec bd des
années 60 absolument c'est à dire que
les mecs ils bouffaient enfin vous avez
vu le film rend les mecs film culte il
bouffe et des conserves s'est couvert de
boutons dans la radio le mâle 20 ouais
alors aujourd'hui un mouvement vous
savez ça qui s'appelle les casseurs de
pub vous connaissez les casseurs de pub
maintenant les casseurs de pub c'est un
mouvement de résistance à l'agression
publicitaire iad journée sans achat et
aujourd'hui c'était la journée le 25e
rang aujourd'hui c'était la journée sans
achat aujourd'hui tous les mecs pour
acheter aujourd'hui ils ont fait un acte
criminel parce que c'était aujourd'hui
la journée sans achat et l inde n aurait
dû sauver les dindons soit posé des buts
ils ont eu le temps d'avoir leur moment
même temps et est donc la publicité il
dit ça ramène l'être humain au rang de
produit 10 la pub bestial is la pub
c'est du totalitarisme soft vous pensez
ça aussi nom de temps en temps la pub
est d'abord rigolote c'est vrai il ya
des trains marrante et puis ça montre
simplement qu'il ya des gens qui ont des
idées
de temps en temps c'est irritant parce
que l'on ment et là on le sait comment
il c'est embêtant parce que la plupart
du temps on an pour les produits pas
chers donc on ment aux petites gens si
le mec qui dit me fais de la publicité
pour une robe du soir à 80 mille balles
et qui dit regardez comme ce serait une
princesse diana une pince à broder bon
ben ça va venir mais c'est surtout les
petits produits pour les petites les
petites choses qui risque d'avoir les
grands-mères et ça c'est pas ça c'est
pas très bien cela dit la pub ça permet
à plein de gens de faire le ce qui
n'existe plus maintenant c'est le court
métrage ouais parce que dans le cinéma
il ya plus beaucoup de courts métrages
par conséquent locale c'est une bonne
école parce qu'il faut et efficace
croyez vous encore qu'une croissance
infinie est possible sur une planète où
les ressources sont limitées
le samedi 25 novembre c'est la journée
sans achat alors faites un geste pour la
terre arrêtez d'acheter
casseurs de pub
ça existe des états unis s'appelle
adbusters il ya tout un mouvement comme
ça de citoyens contre la pub aussi une
journée sans pognon aussi vrai ça serait
drôle c'est pas mal du mec qui ferait à
l'aise alors vous êtes quand même très
branché pognon dont on allait chercher
plancher poney on a l'impression quand
même que vous avez comme ça toute votre
vie j'avais un peu couru après l'argent
soit regardé des guides des catholiques
comme les
non bien sûr que je suis moche et pognon
et c'est comme laisser comme les rôles
c'est vrai on dit par exemple
moi j'ai dit ça plusieurs fois je dis je
on reçoit un scénario on m'a dit vous
serez en costume de lin blanc sur une
plage avec une très belle jeune fille
qui va vous servir des pompes et puis un
mec qui va vous éventé derrière et vous
allez poser votre main dans le sac de
loukoums et l'autre main sur un bon
c'est plus un verbe que d'aller tourner
germinal dans le
dans les corps
mon coeur
est
forcément c'est plus agréable de gagner
de l'argent qui ne pas en avoir mais
c'est plus agréable d'être dans des
beaux endroits que dans des endroits
pour ie c'est plus agréable de bien
manger comme manger de la merde et à ce
propos voudrais parler d'une compagnie
aérienne
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes
vous êtes un peu ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui un bobo c'est ce que c'est
un bobo c'est un bourgeois bohème ça
c'est des gens qui ont des idées de
gauche et qui aime bien le confort de
droite ouais bah oui sinon je vais pas
d'idées de gauche avant
avant vous disiez vous avez des idées de
gauche
s'ils avaient des idées un peu gauche
parce qu'avant avant quand même il
disait j'ai décidé maintenant non non je
suis dire qu'il cherche c'est l'époque
les idées de gauche c'était facile à
déterminer
puisque maintenant les xixe et du gauche
quelle différence y entend didier devaux
schelin et surtout son économie de
marché mais vain ils sont tous sur la
mondialisation
alors vous êtes un jeune papa vous avez
quel âge il à votre enfant de neuf ans
neuf ans
vous avez changé d'avis parce que les
années soixante dix mois j'ai retrouvé
une déclaration sur les enfants a été
terrible les enfants je les déteste
réussir un mariage c'est difficile mais
si on rate ça peut s'arranger un enfant
raté ça ne s'arrête jamais
si j'en avais eu j'aurais pas la
patience de m'en occuper et si des fois
j'avais la patience celui inculte
courait que des notions qui ferait lui à
malheureux
si on est humain qui maintenant est
grand il ne m'en suis pas occupée
boncourt est occupe maintenant n'aurions
s'est offert les ensembles quand on est
vieux d'abord parce qu'on y en a pas
longtemps
c'est entendre ces jeunes quand on a
besoin ouais vivent bien c'est vraiment
parvenu est embêté par des mots mais
c'est facile quand on est vieux on a le
temps de s'en occuper vas-y on pouponne
c'est bien vous avez une vraie
philosophie des ducs ont fait tout dites
moi vous pensez quoi jean yanne de jean
pierre bacri parce que j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu votre successeur dans
la non il a un côté comme vous voyez
cette espèce de jeu passe de l'humour
que vous mais en tous les cas il fait
scruté comme ça complètement oui ben oui
oui le pays entre en bourse mal léché
oui mais c'est ça ouais tu vous en
faites votre grand plaisir c'est de
bouffer à poil tout seul dans la cuisine
ça dépend un peu beauf et hapoel avec
quelqu'un d'autre
je te dis ici on lui arrive d'être
amoureuse bien léché aussi
c'est vrai que là les la solitude n'est
ce pas est un truc qui m'a toujours
épaté quand j'ai vu des bons peut-être
qu'il ya des gens malheureux et qui sont
encore plus malheureux parce qu'ils sont
seuls mais la solitude ne m'a jamais
paru est une chose dramatique parce qu
on est tellement bien quand on est tout
seul vous il ya juste le perroquet qui
vous griffe un peu l'épaule le perroquet
maintenant il va bien parce qu'il a une
copine
et vous emmerde mois alors il faut être
capable dans la cuisine c'est à ce que
je disais là il va vous arriver un truc
terrible ch il te plait
jean yanne nous allume faire de la radio
vous avez voulu faire de la télé vous ai
voulu réaliser des films j'ai voulu
faire des affaires mais une société de
tournage de films français aux états
unis et chine américain en france vous
avez voulu faire de la décoration
d'hôtel mais si vous aviez choisi d'être
que acteurs on sait pas qu'aujourd'hui
vous seriez un des premiers acteurs du
monde
je pouvais pas être seulement acteur
parce que c'est pas moi qui ai choisi
d'être acteur c'était pas mon c'était
pas mon truc moi je suis
[Musique]
voulais faire partie du spectacle et
surtout je voulais écrire des choses
comme des formes demande on me dit mais
qu'est ce que vous regrettez le plus je
dire je regrette simplement que pendant
des années
on mais on n'est pas demandé d'écrire du
dialogue parce que j'étais persuadé que
je serai un bon dialogue c'est le cas
c'est sûr ils gardent le disait tu
devrais cours didier rey mais les gens
voulaient pas mais je dis ça sans
aigreur puisque j'ai fait d'autres
choses plus lucratives mais pour moi
acteurs c'est pas le truc évidemment qui
me passionne le plus et si c'était à
refaire vous referiez la même chose et
j'étais suspect refaire je referais la
même chose dans les grandes lignes c'est
dire que je met par exemple je ferai
beaucoup plus de choses dans la
décoration beaucoup plus de choses dans
l'urbain oui beaucoup de boue plus de
choses dans des choses comme ça à
paraître dans dynamique pas trop dans la
musique je passais bien tu prends c'est
vrai
adoré travailler avec avec des
urbanistes j'aurais aimé faire partie du
projet brasilia ouais tout ce facteur
qua non pas tous aux facteurs mais on
est toujours acteur de quelque chose
dans une société qui nous entoure on a
les maps
lauriane va vous publiez le dictionnaire
des mots qui a que moi qui les connaît
voilà du musulman car sans une jeune
homme
vous êtes le meilleur public du monde et
en plus a vu de nombreux jeunes ont
besoin
c'est un jean veil le nombre me vengerai
scala a well as ya pratiquement un livre
le service et un potier de calme un peu
à mort
je vous faire une interview dicko mais
avant il ya quelques e-mails
l'intéressant laurent révolution alors
il ya un mec qui m'a dit il m'écrit un
truc et d'un fils vie qu'il faut bouger
pendant le jingle mais pourquoi sur
canal pendant une heure et demie
bougeait pas quelle mémoire
et alors il ya le chien mais le chien
kiki dont la photo apparaît sur l'écran
le chien qui a été abattu par son
propriétaire parce qu'ils bougeaient
pendant le jingle
à les antilles et janvier
[Musique]
[Rires]
espérant que samuel subissent pas les
mouvements d'un fils
samuel ne subisse pas le même sort que
qui qui fait quoi ton t shirt samuel
parole a
révélé au daily
mail que le soin de son virage auteuil
est aboutie coach est rigolo viennent
donner la définition jeu voisins les
yeux fermés impôts
comment ce site par un gros mot wet
escroquerie fondamentale ah oui c'est ça
l'ancien
amour oui
imposture
avez-vous pensé ça oui non c'est
l'amusement julie c'est la même chose
que les impôts il ya des gens qui
peuvent pas avoir bien qu'arrivée de
leurs oeuvres puis à des gens très
riches qui peuvent en avoir beaucoup
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
liotta c'est pareil il ya des gens qui
peuvent avoir beaucoup du retard
9 alors ça si c'est un décompte que dans
le dico il ya me ça c'est un truc
formidable il faut saluer à un rêve
parce que dans le nouveau petit robert
il a lille il ya depuis longtemps un
certain nombre de mots ayant notamment
9,9 étoffes et ça c'est quand même fou
que ça l'europe c'est une belle chose
c'est extraordinaire ça ce n'est pas
dans le dictionnaire de l'académie
française c'est pas dans le belge spe et
les académiciens sont jamais la teuf il
n'a jamais couché une meuf ils ont pas
peur des coeurs
battent en battant vous avez vous dit
tout le temps vous je suis pas battant
dès que ça devient un peu dur je
m'arrête c'est vrai que moi je ne suis
pas un fan de l'escalier comme il ya un
ascenseur
j'en prends je peux en prendre chez vous
maintenant qui est très très bien c'est
que le bar vous le savez ce que c'est un
clébard falloir un clébard c'est un goût
c'est artificiel obtenez à la suite
d'une intervention chirurgicale et
consistant à créer une petite poche sous
l'abdomen des fervents du nudisme pour
permettre de conserver leur carte de
crédit et quelques billets de banque sur
eux lorsqu'ils sont nus sur la plage
aurait toujours des phrases comme dans
le robert des exemples nus sur le sable
nous nous amusions à lutter soudain une
douleur fulgurante ne transperce la sans
le faire exprès mon compagnon de jeu
encore forcer son pouce dans mon club
[Applaudissements]
il est et il est pas mal si là aussi il
est très très drôle ce consensus et 1 du
ces c'est un jeune annie maltais
et sautillant mais oui qui se promène
dans la campagne en faisant des cui cui
miaou
la raison c'est un quart
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux